Speaker 1: Donald Trump's rally over the
weekend in Wilmington, North Carolina. Real
America's Voice and right say broadcasting. And
these right wing networks spoke to attendees. A
truly classic moment. Ed Henry and his co-host
speak to an attendee trying to make the case
that there's no neo-Nazis here. Right. And
the attendee says, listen, I respect that
neo-Nazis have a right to voice their opinion.
Speaker 3: Now, there's already articles that
were circulating that I was reading
while he was speaking over in between
things. And they're talking about the white
supremacists that were here in the New York.
Speaker 2: City neo-Nazi, certainly not a
single one. And if any were here, you know,
I respect people's privacy and their their
right to voice their opinions. I mean,
this is you know, I agree with him. I don't
necessarily agree with anybody. I have.
Speaker 1: I don't necessarily I don't
disagree with the neo-Nazis any more than
I disagree with anybody else. I don't know.
Speaker 2: I don't believe. I think this is
America. We all have the opinion to
believe what we choose to believe.
Speaker 1: Dear God. And the girlfriend
looks horrified. Absolutely horrified.
There's no neo-Nazis here, right? I
don't think so. But I mean, listen,
I respect their right to privacy and the right to
voice their opinions. But you disagree with them,
right? I don't know. I don't particularly
disagree or agree with anybody. What
complete and total backfire of the point
that they were trying to make. Here's
a guy interviewed before the speech
who said it is baffling to him that
Biden hasn't been impeached already, that Biden.
Speaker 2: Should be impeached for what he's done
with with was or was what.
Speaker 1: He did with Afghanistan for one rape,
which is the exact same thing Trump would
have done, by the way, us leaving and not.
Speaker 2: Helping our our
troops that are still over there.
Speaker 1: Today. Right. It's just an.
Speaker 2: Embarrassment mind
that a sitting president.
Speaker 1: Can sleep at night.
Speaker 2: Knowing why.
Speaker 1: He's got fire. Jess,
this is a sad state of affairs, I have to tell
you. And the interviewer there, by the way, if she
looks familiar, that's one of Trump's lawyers.
I mean, it's everything is just humiliating.
Here's a guy who believes Trump is a genius.
Speaker 2: I'm going to tell you why I support
President Trump. Yeah, he is a problem solver.
In fact, I'm amazed of his genius.
Speaker 1: Yeah. This guy can't even believe.
How smart Trump is and the number of problems that
he has solved. And then lastly, here is a woman
who is really confused about
like rigged elections, I guess.
Speaker 3: I mean, I think it starts from the
governor. I'll say it. He's corrupt. I don't
think he won. There's no way. Right. When Trump
and all Republicans won the down line that he
won in 2020. And I don't care. Who knows. But
but, you know, it's just. I feel like the state
has a lot of corruption.
Speaker 1: Yep. So all the Democrats
that supposedly won in North Carolina, they
didn't really win. But the Republicans clearly
all did. When a Republican won, they won fair and
square. Even if a lot of these folks were all on
the same ballot, weaponized. Disinformation and
delusions weaponized. I don't know how you undo it